all right antonio brown
uh now with the team
looks great as aryan said
okay uh
they have to say that right they've made
the deal with the devil and i don't mean
that antonio brown's the devil my point
is
they're all in they can't go back now
there can't be any equivocation and you
can't say anything that might upset
antonio brown otherwise you become the
next team that feels the wrath of
antonio brown and i i believe that the
tom brady relationship will keep brown
in line
where maybe others couldn't keep brown
in line yeah um let's and and here's an
interesting exchange
that tom brady had with reporters
yesterday i assume the question's
attached to this as well on the issue of
whether tom brady and antonio brown
spent some time together in the
off-season in preparation for their
inevitable reunion in tampa bay here it
is
tom during the off season after you
signed with the bucks
did you spend any time working out or
throwing with antonio brown and if so
how beneficial might that be now
you know i've been pretty focused on you
know working out with with all my
teammates and um you know it's a good
off season we spent a lot of time at
berkeley prep um it was fun being over
there and
and uh challenging one another and and i
thought we got a good start on things
in a time where um
you know everyone was kind of off but
you know i thought we got a lot of good
work in
and um chris mike
scotty cam
gronk oj
rojo
dari was there so it was it was cool
that's a situation where anything other
than a no is a yes chris
of course have you worked out with
antonio brown well i've been well been
focused on the guys
that's not the question i'm not hashtag
tommy that i brought into yes or no to
one of my private houses and threw with
them there and went down to miami and
threw with them there and did all those
things too
but here's the thing he's he's he's
entitled to do it we saw photos of
antonio brown working out with lamar
jackson yeah there's nothing wrong with
it if he did it i think what they're
trying to do
is slam the door on any of that
discussion because then when some of
these nosy meddling kids come around or
us and start asking more questions
one thing leads to another and the next
thing you know antonio brown's had the
playbook since august that's why i think
they're they're taking this we're not
even starting down that path approach i
wouldn't be shocked i wouldn't be
shocked by that at all you know also to
the fact to where i again i think brady
being new to the team probably didn't
want to disrespect probably doesn't want
to disrespect guys that are already
there and in the locker room like making
it look like i've had this plan all
along i've never been totally satisfied
with you all you guys that's why i've
been working out with them i think
they're trying to avoid that too i mean
that's just what it seems like to me
again we don't know we're speculating
both of us but yeah the fact that he
didn't just
adamantly answer and say no i haven't
worked out with antonio brown since he
left new england that would have been
the answer that's what anybody would
have said so he didn't say that and that
tells me that yes like you're saying too
i believe he's worked out with him and
somewhere in between
he has and i think that rabbit hole goes
a lot deeper and is a lot more
convoluted and interesting than anyone
wants us to know and maybe we'll find
out someday maybe we won't maybe once
antonio brown's upset with the
buccaneers and tom brady he'll he'll
confess to everyone the extent of the
communications and interactions with the
buccaneers and tom brady in advance of
this moment one last point take a break
if you haven't seen it go watch peyton
manning with his film breakdown of a tom
brady throw against the green bay
packers which looked on the surface like
a great throw to rob gronkowski peyton
manning dissects it like a brain surgeon
and throws shade at brady the whole time
it is awesome chris i've watched it five
times it is awesome i it's very
entertaining it's great to see i mean
peyton manning's throwing shots of tom
brady from that standpoint it's
entertaining i don't know he's kidding
he's joking that's what they all say no
he's not well i don't agree with what
he's saying
no it was not he called them out he made
some good points too about not having to
answer zoom calls and the four the four
down thing and he wouldn't admit that
but
i will say again too i don't agree with
peyton manning i think tom brady was
throwing to gronk on that play i do yes
well forget about you i'm on team peyton
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports